und jetzt das heute journal
mit kai soll richter und christian
sievers guten abend drei menschen sind
tot nach einer messerattacke in der
innenstadt von würzburg und es gibt
mindestens fünf verletzte nach der tat
an diesem freitagnachmittag am
barbarossaplatz zwischen hauptbahnhof
und dom mitten in würzburg wo die
polizei den angreifer dann überwältigt
hat der offenbar wahllos passanten
attackierte christian von rechenberg
berichtet es ist freitagnachmittag
mitten in der innenstadt von würzburg
irgendwo soll jemand mit einem messer
unterwegs sein
menschen angreifen ein täter oder
mehrere
die polizei rechnet mit allem kurze zeit
später verdichten sich die hinweise
ein mann hat auf passanten eingestochen
offenbar gezielt frauen
es soll verletzte gegeben haben und tote
nach gegenwärtigem erkenntnisstand ist
kurz nach 17 uhr ein messerstecher in
einem sozial kaufhaus aus heiterem
himmel auf andere kunden in dem kaufhaus
losgegangen und hat der unmittelbar vor
ort drei personen getötet und mehrere
weitere schwerst verletzt ist dann auf
die straße und hat dann in einer
gegenüber liegenden sparkasse noch
einmal bei drei personen schwer verletzt
es haben sich dann wohl auch der straße
schon couragierte bürger ihm in den weg
gestellt die polizei war unheimlich
schnell vor ort
unter den verletzten offenbar ein
kleiner junge bei den schwerstverletzten
sei noch nicht sicher ob alle überleben
würden als bei der polizei im bayrischen
würzburg der notruf eingeht bietet sie
über soziale medien die innenstadt rund
um den barbarossaplatz zu meiden das
ganze gebiet wird abgeregelt
im internet tauchen videos auf sie
zeigen einen umherlaufenden mann
schwarzer hautfarbe offenbar mit einem
messer in der hand
mehrere passanten stellen sich ihm
entgegen versuchen ihn zu entwaffnen zu
stoppen treiben den mann schließlich in
einer seitenstraße die polizei kommt mit
starken kräften stoppt den mutmaßlichen
täter mit einem schuss ins bein
anschließend festnahme hinweise dass es
einen weiteren täter gibt hat die
polizei nicht dennoch bleibt die
würzburger innenstadt gesperrt
diese bilder sollen die festnahme zeigen
[Musik]
nach gegenwärtigen stamm handelt es sich
bei dem täter um einen somalischen
staatsangehörigen der seit 2005 10 hier
in würzburg lebt der zuletzt in einer
obdachlosenunterkunft untergebracht war
die allerletzten informationen besagen
dass er erst im verlauf der letzten zwei
wochen einmal psychisch aufgefallen ist
und deshalb auch in eine psychiatrische
behandlung untergebracht war
bei der einordnung der messerattacke
schließt der innenminister zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt einen islamistischen anschlag
nicht aus
beginn live nach würzburg zu dominik
löschmeister
guten abend wie ist denn die situation
jetzt im moment die hase ich bin ja hier
um kurz vor 9 den würzburger angekommen
und das war schon eine ruhige straße wir
haben ja freitagabend und das wetter ist
auch noch relativ gut da sonst würde man
ja an diesem abend in der stadt
unterwegs sein und es mir gleich schon
aufgefallen dass diese stadt eigentlich
wirklich fast wie ausgestorben ist der
barbarossaplatz das ist ein zentraler
platz in würzburg in der fußgängerzone
und dort hat sich diese tat ereignet und
der innenminister hat ja auch eben von
einer äußeren äußerlichen brutalität
dieses täters gesprochen
der zuerst in einem kaufhaus auf
menschen eingestochen hat dann raus
gegangen ist dann auch in einer
benachbarten sparkasse und es haben wohl
auch menschen couragiert hier
eingegriffen und auch damit wohl
verhindert ja dass noch mehr menschen ja
bei dieser messer attacke gestorben sind
das ist ein sie haben schon gesagt ein
knotenpunkt für busse auch in würzburg
jeder der sich ein bisschen in würzburg
auskennt weiß dass ein sehr zentraler
platz
wir haben gerade auch im film einige der
passanten gesehen die sich dem angreifer
in den weg gestellt haben noch bevor die
polizei da war was wissen sie was hören
sie auch vor ort näheres zu den
umständen
also zuerst glaube ich muss man sagen
die polizei war hier sehr schnell vor
ort hat hier auch sehr schnell
eingegriffen hat den täter ja auch dann
auch schnell dingfest gemacht und auch
mit einem schuss quasi außer gefecht
gesetzt aber was wir hier auch gehört
haben ist das was sie auch gesagt haben
das natürlich passanten versucht haben
irgendwie da auch einzugreifen
und wie gesagt es ist in der innenstadt
situation das ist hier in würzburg dann
noch alischer punkt direkt auch
gegenüber einem krankenhaus der dom ist
in direkter nähe und in der situation
haben
und das ist zu müssen wir da stand jetzt
auch wirklich menschen couragiert
eingegriffen
dominik letztmals live in würzburg
herzlichen dank eine getroffene stadt
ein land das fragen hat es gibt viele
fragen die noch offen sind bayerns
innenminister joachim herrmann wir haben
vorhin im film schon gesehen ist an den
tatort gekommen nach würzburg und jetzt
live bei uns in der sendung guten abend
herr herrmann
guten abend würzburg hat drei tote zu
betrauern heute abend wie geht es denn
den verletzten sie haben vorhin von
schwerstverletzten geredet nach den
letzten informationen sind mindestens
zwei der schwerstverletzten
lebensgefährlich verletzt so das was mir
zuletzt erzählt wurde nicht ganz sicher
ist dass sie auch überleben können
ich kann im moment auch nur beten für
diese menschen es ist alles medizinisch
mögliche für sie getan worden und wir
hoffen dass sie das überstehen
das sind keine guten nachrichten die sie
da für uns haben hermann lassen sie uns
an der stelle vielleicht auch noch mal
über die hintergründe des täters reden
der mann war polizei auffällig sagt
würzburgs oberbürgermeister heute abend
also der polizei vor der tat bereits
bekannt warum
das wird gerade noch näher ermittelt
aber es war nun keine besonders
aufregenden dinge zuletzt allerdings
erst vor zwei wochen ist der täter wohl
psychisch auffällig gewesen deshalb auch
in eine psychiatrische behandlung
eingewiesen worden
was dabei aber dann näher herausgekommen
ist welches ergebnis diese behandlung
hatte das hat sich heute abend noch
nicht klären lassen das wird ein thema
natürlich die nächsten tage seien sie
sagen psychisch auffällig gewesen was
genau ist da passiert
das weiß ich leider auch noch nicht aber
das waren die ja kurz informationen die
wir jetzt immerhin nur wenige stunden
nach der tat schon das zusammentragen
konnten haben sie denn hinweise auf ein
mögliches islamistisches motiv es gibt
einen augenzeugen aus dem kaufhaus der
klar sagt dass der täter bei der übung
seiner wirklich fürchterlichen
gewalttaten seiner mordtaten laute allah
akbar gerufen hat dies deutet auf ein
möglicherweise islamistisches motiv hin
und das ist auch gegenstand der
aktuellen vernehmungen die die polizei
bei dem täter durchführt jetzt ist der
mann ja wie wir seit heute wissen sehr
sehr gefährlich haben sie irgendwelche
anzeichen dafür dass das jemandem schon
früher hätte auffallen müssen
nach dem was wir bislang heute abend
mitgeteilt wurden 1
es habe sich um einen abgelehnten
asylbewerber gehandelt heisst das im
moment können sie das bestätigen
jedenfalls das jahr 2015 als
asylbewerber hier nach deutschland
gekommen ist und seitdem hier in
würzburg gelebt hat zuletzt in einer
obdachlosenunterkunft die näherinnen
ausländerrechtlichen themen
verfahrensablauf sein status das kann
wohl erst im laufe des morgigen tages
geklärt werden also auch warum er weiter
in deutschland war
sollte er tatsächlich abgelehnter
asylbewerber seien ist im moment noch
unklar
ja das kann ich ihnen im moment noch
nicht sagen da muss morgen mit auch wenn
morgen samstag ist denke ich werden wir
das hinkriegen da muss morgen mit den
zuständigen ausländerrechtlichen
behörden der ganze ablauf geklärt werden
er hat man was sagen sie heute abend den
würzburgerinnen und würzburger nach so
einem nachmittag
ich glaube wir sind alle tief betroffen
es ist fürchterlich was da passiert ist
ich habe großen respekt vor den menschen
die der couragiert handelten und den
täter versucht haben zu stoppen
ich bin unheimlich dankbar dafür dass
die polizei sehr rasch am tatort war und
dann mit einem gezielten schuss den
täter gestoppt hat ich bin unheimlich
dankbar all den notärzten und
rettungssanitätern die auch innerhalb
weniger minuten vor ort waren und das
überleben dann der menschen die noch
nicht tot waren letztendlich
sichergestellt haben
ein großartiger einsatz eine großartige
schnelle hilfe und ich habe in einem
persönlichen gespräch auch erlebt dass
eine ganze reihe auch diese
rettungssanitäter der rettungskräfte
selbst zutiefst betroffen waren weil sie
eine derartige brutalität an den opfern
feststellen mussten
wie sie so auch noch wohl nicht häufiger
erlebt haben
von einem sehr traurigen und sehr
verstörenden tag in würzburg joachim
herrmann der bayerische innenminister
reicht angeht fürs gespräch ich dann
gehen auch alles gute und so fiel
zunächst in dieser sendung zu der
messerattacke von würzburg unser
nächstes thema heute abend die korona
lage vorsicht aber keine panik kein
drama aber sorge
so kann man das zusammenfassen was
robert koch institut und
gesundheitsminister heute mitteilen
diesem land das sehnlich auf die
sommerpause wartet angesichts eines
virus das leider keine pause kennt sich
verändert und aktuell in der delta
variante schlagzeilen macht die
pressekonferenzen der
entscheidungsträger also das eine
wir gucken auf die situation in den
krankenhäusern wo sie ihren eigenen
umgang finden müssen mit der lage und
den aussichten patricia schäfer und
sibylle bassler jetzt aus bayern
die delta variante des corona virus seit
kurzem werden im klinikum nürnberg erste
patienten behandelt wir haben eine
patientin mit einer gesicherten delta
virusinfektion
wir betreuen einige patienten ambulant
also auch in der region hier nimmt
stellt er schon über 2.400 1 kopie der
kranke menschen wurden hier bisher
versorgt über die neue variante so der
chefarzt bis immer noch wenig allerdings
scheint für viel ansteckender zu sein
ich betreue eine familie da hat der
jugendliche sohn sich zunächst infiziert
in einem risikogebiet hat die delta
variante in die eigene familie getragen
und der vater der komplett gelähmt war
ist trotz der impfung erkannt er ist
selber ein bisschen anstecken aber die
impfung hat ihn immerhin vor einem
schweren krankheitsverlauf geschützt
im labor des klinikums werden alle
corona proben auf varianten getestet
auffällig bei der delta variante ihre
pool viruslast je mehr virus ich im
nasen rachen raum oder wie lange habt
desto mehr kann ich auch anstecken und
auch schneller anstecken und vermutungen
sind hoch dass wir im august diesen
jahres auch in deutschland zu über 50
prozent delta haben
es könnten im august aber auch schon 90
prozent delta sein dass vermutet dr
ulrich grupe lungenfacharzt in der
kreisklinik bad reichenhall
auch er hatte bisher zwei patienten mit
einer krone variante einen anfang 40
jährigen der nach einer woche wieder
entlassen werden konnte und eine mitte
50 jährige die seit drei wochen bei ihm
auf station liegt zu einer
verschlechterung mit leberentzündung was
wir bei kubi sonst auch nicht selten
sehen
die patientin ist wie gesagt noch
stationär stabil aber wir erwarten einen
doch protegierten also verlängerten
stern verlaufen
die frau war nicht geimpft und hatte
sich bei einer ostseekreuzfahrt mit der
delta variante angesteckt vermutlich in
sankt petersburg
der ebenfalls ungeimpfte mann brachte er
eine variante von einer busreise in
italien mit wir können davon ausgehen
dass urlaubsreisen eine gefahr
darstellen
wir sollten urlaubsrückkehrer engmaschig
überwachen und screenen auf cupid 1900
auf die varianten zurück ins klinikum
nürnberg delta variante sie sei kein
grund zur panik wohl aber zu erhöhter
wachsamkeit zu der chefarzt impfen und
das einhalten der hygieneregeln
auch gegen diese mutation des corona
bieres die einzige chance wenn ich sehe
dass eben kein abstand gehalten ist
keine masken dass man sich um abend der
lungenarzt sieht da quasi das aerosol
dass man da sich gegenseitig in die
nasen geblasen hat dann habe ich angst
dass da wirklich aus der la ola-welle am
schluss eine del tabelle wird
noch lässt sich das vermeiden wenn alle
mitmachen um besser einschätzen zu
können was da auf uns zukommt hilft ein
blick nach israel
die israelis leben ja bereits seit
einiger zeit ihr leben praktisch wie vor
corona das hier sind bilder aus tel aviv
heute die pride parade keine abstand
keine masken viel spaß
israel hat eine vergleichsweise sehr
hohe impfquote und wähnt sich über berg
aber gleichzeitig zieht israels
regierung jetzt die zügel an masken
werden den öffentlichen innenräumen
wieder pflicht wie passt das zusammen
beginnt läuft nach tel aviv zu michael b
warum michael beginnen wir mit dem was
israel durch delta da auf sich zurollen
sieht wofür genau hat die regierung denn
jetzt wieder sorge also eigentlich
sollte die parade heute zum triumphzug
über kroner werden und dann wurde doch
für 12 uhr die wiedereinführung der
masken pflicht den geschlossenen räumen
verkündet verbunden mit der aufforderung
auch auf großen veranstaltungen wie der
maske zu tragen
dabei waren eigentlich fast alle
beschränkungen gefallen nur die einreise
die wurde noch relativ strikt ins land
kontrolliert aber offenbar nicht streng
genug der seit letzter woche kam es dann
doch zu einem deutlichen anstieg wenn
auch auf niedrigem niveau
vor allem mit der data variante von
quasi null auf heute über 220
infektionsfälle an einem tag der sah
sich die regierung dann doch zum handeln
genötigt das ist auf jeden fall ein
anstieg aber es ist nicht vergleichbar
mit der situation zu beginn der pandemie
oder nein die experten sagen alle kein
grund zur panik denn im vergleich zur
zum beginn der pandemie ist es jetzt
doch so dass der großteil der
erwachsenen bevölkerung durch geimpft
ist über 85 prozent der über 18-jährigen
sind zweimal geimpft und das risiko für
sie zu erkranken ist relativ gering auch
an der delta variante zu 90 prozent sind
sie der vogelschuss überhaupt symptome
schwere symptome zu erfahren und zu 95%
notfalls im krankenhaus zu müssen
die problemgruppe das sind die kinder
und jugendlichen das ist etwa ein
drittel der bevölkerung die bisher nicht
geimpft werden dürfen
da versucht man jetzt mit einer großen
impfkampagne gegen zu steuern
insgesamt sagen die experten man muss
sich an corona so etwas wie eine
chronische krankheit für die
gesellschaft gewöhnen aber der korona
beauftragte die regierung sagt aus das
ist jetzt mit der data variante keine
neue große infektionswelle die auf das
land zukommt interessante hintergründe
aus tel aviv michael herzlichen dank
dafür
es ist sehr sehr viel das heute noch zu
notieren ist in der nachrichtenwelt und
das macht jetzt keine silbe dass der
bundestag vor der sommerpause alles
beschlossen hat so wird das verbreiten
so genannter feindes listen verboten
also listen mit namen und teilweise auch
anschriften von politischen gegnern
die betroffenen geraten dadurch oft in
gefahr außerdem können stocker künftig
schneller und härter bestraft werden mit
bis zu fünf jahren gefängnis
bislang waren es drei auch die hürden
für eine strafverfolgung werden gesenkt
jedes kind das ab sommer 2026
eingeschult wird soll einen
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung
erhalten auch das hat der bundestag
beschlossen
doch der bundesrat hat dem gesetz heute
nicht zugestimmt
hintergrund ist ein streit über die
finanzierung der betreuungsplätze
die länder fordern deutlich mehr geld
vom wunsch einen kompromiss soll nun der
vermittlungsausschuss finden ob das noch
vor der bundestagswahl gelingt ist
unklar
außerdem kippte der bundesrat das
umstrittene gesetz für mehr kompetenzen
der bundespolizei sie hätte dadurch mehr
zuständigkeiten erhalten zb bei
abschiebungen und bei der überwachung
verschlüsselter kommunikationskanäle
eine härtere gangart gegenüber russland
darauf haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs der eu geeinigt
so soll es einen plan für mögliche
sanktionen geben mit dem man im
bedarfsfall schnell reagieren könnte der
direkte dialog mit kremlchef putin soll
nicht wieder aufgenommen werden damit
lehnte der eu gipfel einen vorschlag von
deutschland und frankreich
nach dem disput mit ungarn zeigte sich
kanzlerin merkel besorgt die
vorstellungen des landes von der zukunft
der eu seien ein ernstes proben seine
tat hatte im vergangenen jahr die
weltweite black lifes matter bewegung
ausgelöst nun ist klar
der damalige us polizist derek schuh
wien muss für 22 einhalb jahre ins
gefängnis
dieses strafmaß hat das zuständige
gericht in minneapolis verkündet und im
mai 2020 war der afro amerikaner george
floyd dort bei einem polizeieinsatz
erstickt jin hatte minutenlang auf
seinem hals gekriegt
gegen das urteil kann berufung eingelegt
[Musik]
wie gefährlich die mission der
bundeswehr im krisenland mali in
westafrika ist das wurde heute auf einen
schlag ganz klar
zwölf deutsche soldaten verletzt drei
davon sehr schwer
was das heißt möchte man sich kaum
ausmalen es war ein selbstmord anschlag
mit einer autobombe
deutschland beteiligt sich an missionen
der eu und der uno in mali dort sind
islamistische terrorgruppen aktiv die
wohl noch schwerer einzuschätzen sind
als etwa die taliban in afghanistan
was wir wissen über den anschlag heute
und wie die politik in berlin darauf
reagiert zeigt jetzt nicole diekmann
kurz nach 2 uhr heute mittag haben sie
per twitter die offizielle bestätigung
der bundeswehr
es habe am morgen einen
selbstmordanschlag gegeben mit mehreren
verletzten spürbar angefasst informierte
die verteidigungsministerin die presse
erst am frühen abend man habe zuerst mit
den familien der verwundeten sprechen
wollen der anschlag heute macht auf eine
sehr dramatische und schreckliche art
und weise deutlich dass der eid den
soldatinnen soldaten der bundeswehr
schwören dass sie dieses land
verteidigen dass sie in den einsatz
gehen und dass sie zur not auch bereit
sind ihre gesundheit und ihr leben
einzusetzen
nicht nur leere worte sind die
bundeswehr beteiligt sich seit mehreren
jahren an der uno-mission - mal und es
gemeinsam mit anderen nationen in gau im
osten des landes untergebracht derzeit
mit rund tausend soldaten
maly ist der größte einsatz nach
afghanistan immer wieder kommt es zu
zwischenfällen
betroffenheit auch bei der linken die
gedanken gelten heute den verwundeten
und ihren angehörigen aber die debatte
müsse möglichst schnell die überschrift
umdenken tragen
die linke hat dem einsatz in mali zu
keinem zeitpunkt zugestimmt und diese
anschlag zeigt nochmal auf eine sehr
brutale weise wie gefährlich diese
einsätze sind wir sind aufgefordert über
alle einsätze sehr grundsätzlich neu
nachzudenken und ich wünsche mir dass
der nächste bundestag hier sehr solide
neue entscheidungen trifft die fdp
fraktion ist nicht grundsätzlich gegen
den deutschen mali einsatz will ihn aber
dauerhaft geprüft wissen und nicht quasi
automatisch von jahr zu jahr verlängert
was wir brauchen ist eine evaluation von
dem afghanistan einsatz der nach 20
jahren zu ende geht denn wir sind jetzt
schon im jahr 9 in mali und damit wir
eben auch lernen werden wir das eine mit
dem anderen letztlich verknüpft haben
müssen
afghanistan hat eine ganze generation
geprägt und wir möchten eigentlich nicht
dass molly auch eine ganze generation
prägte mindestens zwölf soldaten
verwundet drei davon schwer
das ist die bilanz dieses tages noch
heute nacht soll eine maschine von
deutschland nach kauf staaten und die
schwerverletzten nach hause holen die
missionen mali gilt als die
gefährlichste der bundeswehr weltweit
und natürlich steht auch hier die frage
im raum ob der versuch das land zu
stabilisieren gerade scheitert warum
sind deutsche soldaten dort was können
sie vor ort erreichen und welches ziel
hat ihre mission dazu der heute journal
überblick von uli rottler und dominik
löschmeister
mali liegt in westafrika und ist etwa
dreieinhalb mal so groß wie deutschland
in dem land in der sahelzone leben rund
20 millionen menschen
seit der unabhängigkeit 1960 nimmt die
gewalt in der ehemaligen französischen
kolonie zu zum einen kämpfen die tuareg
seit jahrzehnten für mehr autonomie zum
anderen verüben islamistische gruppen
immer wieder anschläge
das land gilt als rückzugsort für
extremistische kämpfer und menschen
schlepper 2012 verbünden sich teile der
touareg mit den islamisten besetzen den
norden die regierung bricht zusammen
frankreich greift militärisch ein drängt
die extremisten zurück seit 2013 gibt es
die un mission - mag an der auch die
bundeswehr beteiligt ist mit fast 250
todesopfern gilt sie als der derzeit
gefährlichste einsatz der vereinten
nationen
regelmäßig kommt es zu schweren
anschlägen von islamisten im land gab es
innerhalb kurzer zeit zwei
militärputsche von der erhofften
stabilität ist molly weit entfernt es
gab sehr viel dass der bundestag heute
beschlossen hat hat kein selber vorher
schon angekündigt und macht jetzt war
mit teil 2 so sollen verbraucher
bestimmte verträge einfacher kündigen
können zum beispiel für handytarife oder
fitnessstudios außerdem müssen künftig
alle kommunen ab 50.000 einwohnern einen
mietspiegel erstellen und es greifen
schärfere regeln für den insektenschutz
auch die eu will mehr für den
umweltschutz tun mit einer reform der
agrarsubventionen
dabei geht es um hunderte milliarden
euro die nun anders verteilt werden
sollen als bisher
wie darauf haben sich eu-parlament und
mitgliedsstaaten nach monatelangem
ringen geeinigt was heißt das genau
frank bethmann in frankfurt geeinigt hat
man sich darauf dass künftig die gelder
eben nicht mehr nur weitestgehend nach
fläche und hof größe verteilt werden
sondern dass ein teil der milliarden
subventionen an öko regelungen gebunden
sein wird nur wie diese
umweltauflagen konkret aussehen das
steht eben noch nicht fest nur soviel
insgesamt geht es um 270 milliarden euro
für die jahre 2023 bis 2027 um bis zu
ein viertel davon wird jetzt nach
klimafreundlichen kriterien vergeben
kurzum es wird künftig nicht mehr
reichen in anführungsstrichen nur bauer
zu sein um an die voerder fleischtöpfe
zu kommen man muss eben auch nachweisen
dass man künftig was für die natur macht
das ist gewollt genauso wie es gewollt
ist kleinere höfe dadurch zu stärken
trotzdem zeigen sich umweltschützer sehr
enttäuscht wie gut ist die reformen und
wirklich um die agrarbranche
klimafreundlicher zu machen
ja ich formuliere es mal so hätte man
gesagt geld gibt es künftig nur noch
wenn umwelt kriterien erfüllt werden
dem klimaschutz hätte ist mehr gebracht
aber so funktioniert die politik eben
nicht andererseits ist der trend ja
eindeutig nicht nur für die
landwirtschaft gilt am klimaschutz kommt
keiner mehr vorbei
nicht die industrie nicht der handel und
auch nicht das dienstleistungsgewerbe
umweltschützer haben druck gemacht wucht
aber bekommt das ganze nun weil auch die
kapitalmärkte umgedacht haben wir
künftig nicht nachweisen kann dass sein
geschäftsmodell nachhaltig ist dem droht
der geldhahn abgedreht zu werden sollen
große immobilienkonzerne enteignet
werden über diese frage können die
berliner wohl am 26 september abstimmen
für einen entsprechenden volksentscheid
sein die nötigen unterschriften
zusammengekommen bestätigte die
landeswahlleiterin der initiative
deutsche wohnen & co enteignen will rund
240.000 berliner wohnungen in den besitz
einer anstalt öffentlichen rechts
überführen und gemeinwohlorientiert
verwalten lassen
ein tornado hat im südosten von
tschechien gleich sieben dörfer
verwüstet mindestens fünf bewohner
wurden getötet
außerdem gab es etwa 200 verletzte
insgesamt wurden rund 1000 häuser
beschädigt oder ganz zerstört unter den
trümmern werden weitere opfer befürchtet
bei dem unwetter in südmähren kamen auch
tennisballgroße hagelkörner runter wie
tornados entstehen dazu später mehr
ja so viel von uns weitere informationen
zur messe angriff in würzburg jederzeit
natürlich auf unseren zdf heute online
kanälen und nachher im heute-journal
update mit gundula gause gegen 0 uhr 10
und jetzt gucken wir auf die politische
stimmung in deutschland mit matthias
fornoff und dem zdf politbarometer von
uns allen hier guten ab guten abend
willkommen zum politbarometer
die nachrichten der letzten wochen
klingen gut
die sieben tage incident sinkt die zahl
der todesfälle auch gleichzeitig steigt
die impfquote etwa ein drittel der
bevölkerung ist vollständig geimpft
soweit stimmt die richtung wenn da nicht
delta wäre die zuerst in indien
aufgetaucht
besonders ansteckende variante des virus
breitet sich in deutschland aus
noch sind die zahlen niedrig aber die
befragten im politbarometer befürchten
dass das nicht so bleibt
67 prozent rechnen damit dass es bei uns
wegen der korona mutationen zu einer
vierten welle kommen wird 29 prozent
glauben das nicht
für die meisten ist corona also noch
nicht unter kontrolle
deshalb ist die mehrheit auch dafür
vorsichtig zu bleiben
die große mehrheit von 79 prozent
wünscht sich weiterhin eine masken
pflicht beim einkaufen
20 prozent wollen das nicht beim fahren
mit bus und bahn ist die zustimmung noch
deutlicher 87 prozent sind dafür
dabei masken zu tragen nur elf prozent
dagegen
fast zwei drittel der befragten finden
die geltenden coroner regeln weiterhin
gerade richtig
gleichzeitig nimmt die sorge um die
eigene gesundheit weiter ab 56 prozent
glauben dass das virus für sie kein
gesundheitsrisiko darstellt
bei der sonntagsfrage gibt es nach den
starken veränderungen vor zwei wochen
nun wenig bewegung
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
könnten sich cdu/csu leicht verbessern
29 prozent plus 1 die spd käme auf 14
die afg auf 10 beide minus 1 die fdp bei
10 prozent die linke bei sieben die
grünen erreichten 22 prozent alle
unverändert
die union also deutlich stärkste kraft
vor den grünen
damit hätte schwarz grün als einziges
zweierbündnis eine mehrheit reichen
würde es ansonsten nur noch für die
sogenannte deutschland koalition aus
cdu/csu spd und fdp
doch das muss nicht so bleiben denn nur
19 prozent denken dass es heute schon
klar ist wer die bundestagswahl gewinnt
80 prozent glauben das nicht vor der
letzten bundestagswahl waren 39 prozent
der meinung der sieger steht schon fest
60 prozent sahen das anders
das rennen scheint also für die meisten
befragten diesmal offener zu sein
trotzdem erwarten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
61 prozent dass die union die
bundestagswahl gewinnen wird nur neun
prozent sehen die grünen als gewinner
und noch weniger gerade mal drei prozent
die spd
auch auf unserer liste der wichtigsten
politiker gibt es wenig veränderungen
auf der skala von plus 5 bis minus 5
bewertet nach sympathie und leistung
bleibt annalena baerbock schlusslicht
etwas verbessert minus 0,1 davor jens
spahn 0,0 unverändert dann christian
lindner 0,1 verschlechtert sahra
wagenknecht 0,4 etwas besser armin
laschet 0,4 schlechter robert habeck
verbessert sich deutlich 1,0 olaf scholz
1,0 etwas besser
markus söder auf rang drei 1,3 mit
leichten verlusten
genauso wie winfried kretschmann auf
platz zwei 1,7 ganz vorne weiter angela
merkel 2,4 verbessert nach ihrem absturz
in den bewertungen hat sich der wind für
annalena baerbock noch nicht gedreht
aber auch die beiden anderen
kanzlerkandidaten werden nicht gerade
mit vorschusslorbeeren überhäuft
47 prozent glauben armin laschet wäre
geeignet als bundeskanzler aber genauso
viele bezweifeln dass olaf scholz trauen
49% kanzler zu 44 prozent nicht bei
annalena baerbock sind die befragten
klarer nur 29 prozent glauben sie kann
bundeskanzlerin 65 prozent trauen es ihr
nicht zu in dieser woche hat nun auch
die union ihr wahlprogramm vorgestellt
sie wirbt darin unter anderem damit
keine steuern zu erhöhen und unternehmen
zu entlasten
wie groß ist das vertrauen der wähler in
die ankündigungen der parteien im
allgemeinen nur 23 prozent sind der
meinung dass die ankündigungen der
parteien vor der wahl danach im großen
und ganzen eingehalten werden
drei viertel der befragten aber glauben
nicht daran
die zweifel waren bei den letzten beiden
bundestagswahlen ähnlich groß die
deutschen blicken also eher skeptisch
auf wahlprogramme und versprechungen vor
der weit so können sie im günstigsten
fall danach positiv überrascht werden
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer punkt zdf.de vielen dank
für ihr interesse
das nächste politbarometer gibt es dann
am 16 juli und nach dem wetter geht's
hier gleich weiter mit einem heute
spezial deutschland in der notaufnahme
ihnen noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der
außergewöhnlich starke tornado und
tschechien war katastrophal
grundsätzlich gilt damit sich ein
tornado bilden kann braucht man eine
gewitterwolke dabei steigt feucht-warme
luft nach oben aber das reicht noch
nicht
mit der höhe muss sich die windrichtung
und -stärke ändern
oben wird der wind stärker und es kommt
zur scherung es bildet sich ein
rotierender schlauch der in die wolke
gezogen wird die feuchtigkeit in diesem
aufwind schlauch kondensiert und es
bildet sich eine trichter wolke auch
funnel genannt das ist allerdings noch
kein tornado von dort wächst der wolken
christel nach unten
sobald er den boden erreicht hat ist es
ein tornado je wärmer die luft desto
größer die unwettergefahr wie zum
beispiel von starkregen hagel und
tornados
und auf unseren satelliten film der
letzten 24 stunden sehen wir rote
farbkleckse und hier sehen sie ganz
besonders in diesem bereich richtung
österreich und tschechien den cluster
der diesen tornado ausgelöst hat und der
zug dann relativ rasch ostwärts ab
schauer und gewitter gab es bei uns
heute auch im süden deutschlands die
lassen der nachts nach höchstens noch im
osten einige im süden klart es auf
temperaturen dort bis 9 grad und 15 grad
an der nordsee morgen dann schau im
erzgebirge und im emsland sonst bleibt
es größtenteils trocken vielleicht mal
schauer an den alpen und saß bei
temperaturen bis 27 grad zum beispiel im
südwesten und 21 grad im vogtland die
nächsten tage am sonntag gibt es
badewetter pur bis 30 grad ab montag
kommen wieder heftige unwetter von
westen damit ein schöner abend